[Music]
this is star talk sports edition and
this is going to be a cosmic queries
grab bag
i love those because they go everywhere
and we're responding to your depths of
curiosity out there we're going to do
three segments in the first segment
we're going to do cosmic queries in the
second segment
more cosmic queries and in the third
segment even more and i got with me my
co-host chuck nice jack hey neil good to
have you there all right professional
comedian and i got a former professional
soccer player
in the guys of gary o'reilly gary i feel
privileged to have you have access to
you
i feel the reciprocal feelings oh well
thank you thank you and we said in
previous episodes you there's a wiki
page where your legs are on full display
and chuck couldn't stop talking about it
[Laughter]
and you know i i think i'm pretty good
with grab bag cosmic queries but i know
someone out there who's better we all do
he's beloved a friend of star talk my
friend my colleague charles liu
hello neil it's a pleasure and chuck and
gary great to see you guys again thank
you so much
because whatever i know you know more of
it that's what
that's what
not at all neil it is evidence that that
the geek spectrum
goes infinite in each direction okay
wherever you are in it there's someone
geekier than you and arms reach away and
that's what we've got right here i would
just like to think that we complete each
other oh i don't know
i can supplement and vice versa
we're recording this right in the middle
of the olympics and finally finally
track and field kicked in
so um the chuck are you on top of that
yes absolutely the uh the olympics i'm
i'm watching none of it
how is that possible how can you avoid
it okay charles
okay i asked the wrong person i'm gonna
be very honest i turn over i can't find
it i can't find it anywhere i'm serious
charles how have you been
doing with the olympics oh i have been
following it i've been watching some
stuff and i confess that i was staying
up till all hours once or twice this
past week just checking things out live
because somehow there is a difference
between watching something happen in
real time compared with watching it
packaged in prime time
all right so gary chuck you got the you
got the questions out there so let's see
what we've got and all these from
patreon yes they are um i'll start off
chuck um follow the next one
jay maggie here we go is oxygen
deprivation a major case with swimmers
who train and compete for olympic gold
what kind of transformation do their
bodies go through in being able to push
their bodies while getting less oxygen
okay charles
yeah charles let me tighten that
question a little bit and ask
if
are the better
for athletes
better because they do well with less
oxygen
or because they've done something with
their physical fitness so that they
always have more oxygen available ah uh
both are kind of true and i presume it
doesn't it doesn't focus just on
swimmers just anybody with great
muscle performance and in fact there is
a method of blood doping where you add
oxygen uh hemoglobin rich stuff into
your body so there's a way to cheat on
that too but oxygenation is a very good
question and yes but wait if you add if
you add oxygen-rich hemoglobin that's
not a separate chemical different from
the rest of what's if you have a higher
percentage of hemoglobin in your blood
then you can process oxygen a little bit
better but then you won't get caught
right yes well that or supposedly but
actually i believe they call that the
keith richards
today
you train altitude charles yes you one
of those blood
obviously he's able to take in more
oxygen you keep it knowing that you're
performing at sea level and then you
dope yes with your own blood with your
own blood tour de france cyclists are in
fact um infamous for doing this kind of
work but uh and no no disrespect to
people who don't like this guy one of
the reasons why he's mine not to
disrespect him okay yeah well no no no
no i'm saying i understand why you may
not like him but
one of the greatest cyclists of all time
because of his uh the way his he
metabolized uh
he was able to retain oxygen in his
blood is uh lance armstrong
well his doping is now well recorded in
legendary and if he were not doing that
maybe he would not be one of the
greatest cyclists of all time but that's
another conversation for another time to
answer specifically the oxygen nation
you just disc chucked nicely i know man
i was just
well
i said if you don't like them i
understand no no okay it has nothing to
do with like it was just the facts of
the circumstances but okay go on go on
charles with oxygenation is very
interesting for swimmers for example
various uh
asthmatics people who have a hard time
taking in air sometimes are told to swim
to help them deal with that better some
of the
world's greatest swimmers of all time
actually have asthma for example amy van
dyken who won many gold medals in
swimming
was asthmatic and as a result
for example the way that she swam she
was able to use her muscles and work
her body despite the fact there was a
difficulty in her being able to take in
air and so it's because you force your
body and train it to breathe at these
regular intervals so it's really a
breathing exercise at that level
not only breathing yes but also the
ability to do something very effectively
even though you're not in taking more
oxygen
okay so what about the sprints like the
50 meter uh sprint that they don't even
come up for air so no they don't that's
right yeah yeah well who's usain bolt is
so good he actually held his breath the
entire time he was running just to try
and make it fair
just to make it fair
can't tell if you're joking or serious
he was still tying his shoes when
everyone else began
but yeah it's true uh the the people who
are doing the 50 meter sprint swims over
the 20-ish seconds where they're working
like crazy they might come up for one
breath that's it mm-hmm
wow
yeah all right keep it going what else
are we okay yeah wow look at that well
we're not going to make you hold your
breath for the next question so i got to
add something astrophysical here so
earth's atmosphere didn't always have
oxygen uh it was likely carbon dioxide
in its very earliest stages and the
whole ecosphere at the time
fed on carbon dioxide and and and
released oxygen as a byproduct
and so um the biggest climatic change
ever was was the conversion of our
atmosphere from
co2 based to oxygen
correct significantly the great the
great oxygenation took hundreds of
millions of years and it was the most
significant extinction event in the
history of life on earth
oh wow so it was like for us uh what
global warming will be
cool very possibly very exciting global
warming is happening on this time scale
of human lifetimes that's happening to
take care of hundreds of millions of
years yeah way different scale yeah so
oxygen then enabled a whole other level
and classification of metabolism to take
place that's right it's like rocket fuel
for
for
for microscopic animals
but that took it took forever to evolve
that and everything that didn't evolve
that died out died
there it is okay i'll give you another
question give me another all right here
we go this is uh michael de cola
and he says hey guys
which sport of all sports
and your scientific opinions requires
the highest level of eye hand
coordination and why baseball hockey
tennis badminton ping pong
oh i love it let's get to that we got to
take a quick break
when we come back we're going to fight
over who thinks
well
clearly in soccer there's no hand-eye
coordination because they'll use their
hands so
so you're out you're not in this con
you're not in this conversation
keepers oh i'm i'm in this conversation
but it doesn't have to be about soccer
okay when we come back more star talk
sports edition cosmic quarries with my
friend and colleague charles liu
we're back star talk cosmic queries
grab bag all cosmic queries all the time
on this in this episode i got charles
lou with me he's an astrophysicist with
the city university of new york and i've
known this guy for 20 something years
and
wherever i am on the geek spectrum
he's beyond
he's
multiple steps beyond so that's why we
see a logistic relationship all right we
work work with one another thank you
as you said in the first segment we
complete one another maybe that's what
it is uh and chuck chuck nice and gary
o'reilly let's do this okay so what was
that next question
uh uh when we last uh went before we
left michael dicola wanted to know which
sport of all sports and your scientific
opinions requires the highest level of
hand-eye coordination and why i'm going
to vote real quick and i would i would
not have had this answer except for the
olympics i saw two days ago
and i have to say table tennis because
oh my gosh what the hell are they doing
how are they how it is happening and i
can't even follow it i'm dizzy just
looking at him and they're actually
playing the game so i vote for table
tennis hand-eye coordination
i
agree that that is very impressive but
my watching has led me to believe the
thing that's even more crazy and even
harder is fencing
i cannot tell when people score i just
can't see the blades
it is funny where they just sort of
remove the mask and cheer and say what
the hell just happened so
fast and we should also qualify right
neal uh and gary i know you're about to
say something about this too um there
are many different versions of hand-eye
coordination there's the whole hand like
in fencing there's individual finger
craft right there's the ability to move
the arm in general uh is the very
complex system so the term hand-eye
coordination is very complicated and
there could be many correct answers to
this question
and for me i kind of like the triple
play in baseball that requires very high
hand eye speed coordination and accuracy
um but still the ping pong my my head is
still bouncing back and forth from three
days ago matches that i saw uh so who
else so gary
um
you don't get a vote here because soccer
no i have a non-scientific opinion so
i'm kind of just
i'm running for fun as it were okay um
so it's a non-olympic sport but i have
to push forward formula one racing
to be able to travel at 200 miles an
hour coordinate everything in your ears
that's coming from your team to assess
intuitively the situation of your car on
the road at those speeds whilst driving
i would push that forward but there's an
argument for and against i'm sure
my argument against that is everybody's
going 200 miles an hour right so
and the car is helping a little bit
it's not going in a straight line that's
the thing with formula one it doesn't go
in a straight line you've got it you
have to steer that's true you do have to
stay here i i tell you man i'm confused
now because ping pong is a blurringly
fast sport where you can't even follow
the ball and they're like the way
they're and i don't know how they create
that much force to slam that little
teeny ball that doesn't even i can't
even throw it and they are
and they're smashing it so that it
travels through but then fencing
is so incredible the way they're moving
these foils in such a way that they're
blocking each other and you can't even
see it and they're saying things like
hello my name is igno montoya you're my
father
no here it is i think they should
replace lightsaber i mean um
i think they should replace fencing with
um lightsabers all right there it is i'm
now i'm watching all the time even
olympics are not
you know that'd be the the future of
fencing so
lightsaber fighting in star wars is much
more like the style of playing kendo
which is a sword fighting technique
different oh yes i like kendo yes i know
yes so instead of like cutting you in
half with them you just wind up hurting
yeah you just end up with a knot on your
head like this
they're heavily armored yeah yeah but uh
i don't know when formula one is going
to become an olympic sport that all
right so what do you guys think about
baseball baseball
baseball triple play is tremendously
difficult very hard for uh the hand-eye
coordination of pitchers got to throw
the ball at 100 miles an hour and then
land in another box yeah a little tiny
box and then the batter's gotta you know
make sure that you're taking a little
stick and hitting this ball that's
coming towards you at 100 miles an hour
very complicated so really every sport
has a case to make for what is the most
difficult hand-eye coordination i don't
think we can arrive today on a truly
it's just not soccer because they don't
use their hands that's all i'm saying
what is it
what's your problem
i love you but in this case
i got nothing for you
wow
what are you gonna do some serious stuff
all right here we go next question's up
and it's
v o leita and it's broke down
frenetically for us and my mum izzy
here we go breaking news
i am finally 13 years of age she's a
teenager
what are the weirdest sports to ever
officially be part of the olympic games
past or present
and why though so has anyone got i got a
vlog i got to vote here
i got to vote here so it has to be the
tug of war which was in the first few
olympics and they said no this is we're
not doing this anymore
so that was just kind of weird right the
tug of war so the rule was as i
understand it everybody in the tug of
war had to have a common
um uh
a profession
and they have to dress in whatever it is
that that profession required of them so
that it was a unit it wasn't just random
people from your country so it would be
like all police officers or fire people
or whatever and so so it turned out the
brits kept winning it because they put
their bobbies in it you know the police
and they have these long boots with
steel shanks
in the at the heel
and so once they dug in their heels you
can't un-pull that and so they were
winning every time and they just they
just gave up in the tug of war so we
broke we broke the sport of tug of war
yeah i think so yeah so tug of war that
was kind of weird technology issue yeah
yes yes they probably could have gotten
around that but that was kind of weird
and i would say the one of the weirdest
sports we still have not including all
the really weird ones just traditionally
weird the triple jump i i can't
get around that one i'm sorry
all right that's gotta that's good
there's so much physics in it let's not
just let's let's not just jump once
let's jump three times
first hop first and then it's like
winning then skip and then it's just
getting
so happy it's a happy event
you get to skip in the middle yeah all
right so okay that's my vote go all
right
my obviously as i've said already
non-scientific is speed walking
oh
that i you know i get walking around but
walking like that um you know to all
these so it's like go as fast as you can
just don't run right just go as fast as
you can and look almost as ridiculous as
you can doing it yeah
so with respect to every speed walker
nobody listens to speed walking yeah
nobody else goes
walking is cool because
the rule that you have to have one foot
on the ground at all times is a
fascinating physical requirement but
that's not why they look weird
right they look weird because the no
that's no no no they look weird because
the leg that's coming under your body
has to have a locked knee yeah
so you so
yes yes so as the you put you put down
your foot in front of you as your body
passes over that foot your leg has to be
straight
and so otherwise you ever see the
posters keep on trucking you could you
could
you could truck faster than you can
speed walk if because you're not limited
by the leg going straight under your
body and so it's the straightening of
the leg that shifts the hips up and down
and gives you that jiggle wiggle waggle
walk that they've got it just looks
painful so chuck how about you what
sport is that very quickly ribbon
dancing what the hell
you mean gymnastics rhythmic gymnastics
no with the ribbon yeah
there's only one event there's also the
little ball that you could dance with
too yes that too oh that goes in with
the ribbon dancing for me it's
ridiculous stop it is what i'm saying
[Music]
take your ribbon and wrap a gift and
take your ball and go to the beach
and leave it out of the damn thing leave
it out of the olympics
i love rhythmic gymnastics
i got one more one more thing it's not
weird but i have to confess my uh urban
ignorance so
i think i was maybe 20 like
embarrassingly probably a little younger
but still embarrassingly old the day i
learned
that the in water polo
never touching the ground never touch
the bottom of the pool right because
it's like seven eight nine feet down and
i said what
and so i so i i don't know that i don't
know that counts as a sport that is
weird but i thought it was weird that
they had to swim the entire time i said
who would do that i guess that makes it
harder if you're just trying to throw
the ball
the physical fitness of water polo uh
athletes uh just offices
i think i think it's an uncelebrated
fact about what they do and how and why
they do it yeah yeah
all right all right let's get one more
before we take our next break go ahead
gary kaley kaylee
um hi chuck hi everybody
are there very many participants in the
sports world working directly with
scientists in the pursuit to figure out
it's a long question by the way um pull
up a chair out of how durable the human
body can be and what these athletes can
accomplish i've heard people saying we
should have at least one perfectly
average person competing against the
world's best in the olympics so can we
have some frame of reference and a laugh
so basically chuck so basically chuck
this is what kaylie sell is saying
how much would they need to pay you
chuck
right to do gymnastics next to simone
biles and what is the statistical
likelihood you would survive to do
another star talking
oh that's the rewording of the question
we will find out when we come back
whether chuck should be in the olympics
so we can all laugh at him
to everybody else on star talk
we're back for our third and final
segment of stark talk
sports edition cosmic queries grab bag
edition i got charles lou charles how do
we find you on the internet
uh i tweet at chuck liu c-h-u-c-k-l-i-u
and generally just find me
around just good okay fine
just open some doors there's a turn on
the internet
and you'll find chuckles
and and and gary you're my three left
feet i think yeah yes and i like a bit
like charles you turn on the internet
and you can find me
you'll be everywhere yeah and and chuck
nice is a chuck nice comic yes sir
correctly very good very good so we left
off i forgot was this question directed
to charles liu or chuck nice this is a
chuck
the average person we want to see
perform right so they want to see just
how good
the best in the world actually are by
putting what they are con this is kaylee
sell by the way she is saying right how
much do we need to pay chuck to do
gymnastics next to simone biles
and what is the statistical likelihood
you would try to break
i like the idea that we get a reminder
of what is average right that's a level
that's a facet so instead of the world
record line on the pool this should be
the chuck nice line you know moving is
yeah which by the way would be a kiddie
pool
i know but what it does i mean spinning
that 180 what it does is make you
realize
just
how good these athletes are and when you
say elite i think in some instances it
doesn't do them justice well right
if i ever swam against an olympic uh uh
in an olympic meet
uh the other swimmers would also have to
wear swimmies
to make it even for me because i bet you
that that would like ruin them like
actually swimming with swim
will help you out as soon as those
little inflatable things that are on
your stick on your arms okay all right
as i was wondering so here's the
difference there are events where you
would break if you attempted them but we
all can walk and we know how to run and
most of us know how to swim so i think
those are more typical of where you can
put an average person in and see where
they would land i think that would be an
interesting um
uh exercise bunch up do the the balance
beam or four exercises now let me just
tell you you could not pay me to do the
balance beam oh
for two reasons one yeah i know what
they are i actually and there's two
reasons
and i like them both
that's the end of that joke
okay so that's it all right and the
second thing is that i have a permanent
case of the twisties so
you know all you have to do is a double
pike dismount and you don't have to
twist
that's true okay so so here it is chuck
i'm going to quote one of your brethren
uh stephen wright okay he he says i'm
not afraid of heights
i'm afraid of widths
okay you gotta love that that was good
that's not the fall it's the landing
right
right right right right all right let's
get another one going here in our third
and final segment so what else you got
you guys going back and forth yeah well
this is michael main michael means says
hey neil and charles uh lucas my
ten-year-old science enthusiast wishes
to know how many gymnasts jumped so high
during their floor routines not how many
but how how is it they jumped so high
he forgot to do how do gymnasts uh jump
so high uh during their floor he didn't
forget to do you added a word that
wasn't there
okay which no gymnast jumped so high
that's all don't be blaming it on the on
michael let me tell you something
michael didn't write this question the
way i told him to
[Laughter]
plus
he should let his ten-year-old ask the
question not himself
we're answering lucas here not michaels
okay an excellent question and michael
thank you for phrasing the question for
lucas on lucas's behalf the answer is
twofold one is gymnasts have so much
muscle power per cubic inch of their
body
that they're able to launch themselves
in very very effective ways kind of like
a way a basketball player can elevate
above
the rim but in this instance it's
elevating their whole bodies in unusual
and fast could it be that they're
smaller they're smaller being smaller
helps
because a flea can jump many times it's
height but a hippopotamus can't that's
right so that's that's part of it right
imagine a jumping hippopotamus that
would be amazing oh i would love to see
that but the second point which
sometimes people don't know as much is
that have you seen baby hippos they're
the cutest thing they do jump with all
four feet okay and they didn't cut you
in half with their mouths
they are they are powerful powerful
animals yeah they're all jaw yeah okay
so go on the other part is that a lot of
people don't realize that in the floor
exercises there are springs under the
floor
it is a very small amount of give and
elasticity on the floor just uh
in order to allow the athletes to have
that extra push and see all the cool
things that we get to see when they are
performing their acts
so that means the energy that they
give themselves by jumping high when
they hit the the pad again
that energy goes into the spring and
goes back to them and it's not absorbed
by anything so that so there's no
dissipation of the jumping energy now
apparently somebody wasn't content with
the floor exercises and they introduced
the trampoline to the olympics
amazing we're not jumping high enough
right right you guys going 30 feet in
the yeah
that's
beautiful
okay keep them keep it coming give me
some more all right
thank you lucas ten-year-old yes uh
we're going to fill one in which kind of
seems off-topic but i think we'll find a
way to make this work josh has asked
what fields because a physics graduate
work in
minus teaching
i wish to switch my degree to physics
but i am worried about the lack of job
prospects well we are a science sports
show so charles do we have the answer
here
we do wait he's asking what if he's
majors in physics is there a job yeah
you know wait the thing is so he's
thinking he's looking in in the want ads
or whatever they are today and say
physicist is needed that's not how this
works right oh no yes charles take this
take this from me go yeah and by the way
we're not indeed.com
regrettably we may not have the job to
offer but let me provide encouragement
uh as neil was alluding to physics is
essentially the understanding of how the
world and the universe work my
undergraduate degree is in physics yeah
i have one undergraduate degree in
physics as well
in addition to astronomy and
astrophysics the point is that most
people
would love to hire a physicist
for doing something other than teaching
for example
helping athletes be more effective in
their athletic behavior because they
know the physics of the human body the
physics of the equipment the physics of
the venue
what you need to do
in order to take advantage of those
opportunities in the world after you've
attained a physics degree is to love
what you do
loving the physics and understanding
what's happening allows you to extend
yourself into different areas of the
world which you might not have thought
of was physics and in the in the
process literally change how those
fields work and it's and i may add
because
charles and i co complement each other
yes uh no no
because charles and i complete each
other let me add
that
physics is not so much a body of
knowledge
as it is insight into the operations of
nature
so
employers who know that do very well
and you know who are among them google
has hired physicists my wife has a phd
in mathematical physics and was hired by
michael bloomberg
when he began his entire financial
empire
when she was hired in there he had only
less than 100 employees and he himself
has degrees in math and physics and when
he became the youngest partner ever at
solomon brothers his mother said but
you're not using your physics degree and
then when he left with 30 million
dollars and founded a company a tech
info tech company but you're not using
your physics degree then he becomes a
multi-billionaire then he runs you're
not using a physics degree the fact is
he was using his physics degree every
single day
that's right so shut up mom
no
no never tell mom the show
always said sag because he's a comedian
he's a logistic
but but the realization yes if you want
to switch to physics because you really
love it and you want to study the way
the universe works do it and you will
find the employment opportunities there
opening up for you wait wait and if you
really just into just the physics for
the physics sake then you then you can
be a physicist and be a research
professor somewhere but if you don't
want to teach and you don't want to do
that 99 other places will do will will
take you because you will see the world
the way others do not as a juxtaposition
of matter emotion
and energy in fact charles and i are
co-authors on a book published in the
year 2000 which is basically about
astronomy in the universe
however
the content was organized by the physics
principles of matter motion and energy
and that was sort of an innovative way
to think about
information and knowledge and how it
works to bring us the world that we know
and understand and love one universe at
home in the cosmos yeah
time for like one more question we got
more another question all right
this is from roman precop is there any
technology which could make i.e javelins
fly further i think charles you've got
this we may have touched on this no i
got this i got this it's called ruckus
[Laughter]
low-hanging fruit has been picked
what is it but a a what is a a rocket
but a javelin with a rocket on it yeah
yeah that's that's right so charles
didn't they already do this because they
did the opposite of this no no no they
do so they moved the center of gravity
by there's a weight so they moved it
further back
and so that actually made the javelins
throw
less distance but that's because because
the space in the stadium they couldn't
contain the thrown javelin in the
stadium without risking
killing someone on the facing stands can
you imagine someone else we only lost we
only lost four fans
and and an athlete in the five thousand
meters that was taking them that
happened to me
you know imagine how that explaining
that was there was also
charles wasn't there some sort of
feathering on the tail of the javelin as
well that they were using to make it fly
so can we explain that as well
well aerodynamically speaking when you
have something in the tail of an object
moving it helps stabilize the motion and
create a better trajectory and what we
always want to do when we're trying to
throw things that are not round or even
round to some extent is to try to make
sure it doesn't wobble or make too many
changes in its profile to the air as it
moves through the air because that'll
bring up more air resistance an
effective thing that will create more
air resistance i see the the fletching
creates yeah a little bit of air
resistance by existing but what it does
is is that makes the net air resistance
of the entire system much smaller
cool so so this is why to just go off
sport here uh this is why you can throw
a spiral
uh football farther than throwing it in
any other
sort of
kind of trajectory right a spiral goes
farther because it maintains the same
what how did you call it profile to the
air
as it moves as it moves through okay
very cool
so but so we don't want them to fly
farther that's the point because we want
to contain it within the stadium well we
can build bigger stadiums but that's not
cost effective
let's do one more
was there one on the paralympics there
yes there was uh this is a question from
peter jacobs from queensland australia
shouldn't we allow paralympic swimmers
to wear prosthesis or thesis
prostheses yeah prosthesis thank you
interesting well um
in my opinion it would be fine if
everyone wore the same kind of
prosthetic that would allow them to be
performing on a fair level playing field
that's kind of hard to know right
paralympic
athletes all need different
kinds of prosthetics
uh
and so if you are going to that's part
of the interesting challenge of
designing the sports and how they would
then you wind up with a yeah a
circumstance and and really um
this is philosophical as opposed to
physical but in my opinion when a
paralympic athlete uh is performing
that person is whole
that person is not incomplete and needs
a prosthetic to complete them they are
who they are and so competing with that
in mind in that attitude is in my
opinion probably much more meaningful
than athletic competition than
prostheticizing everyone to be sort of
uh uniform in that way right otherwise
you'd be like well
nothing you said has any rebuttal
at all yeah which is why i can't stand
it because you couldn't i can't make a
joke you can't even make
what you're saying is to say let's put
on a prosthetic means we have to turn
you into us in order to watch you
compete and that's just wrong
oh my gosh
what an answer charles what an answer
amen that is really good
damn and of course uh if you want to
cross over to one of our other postings
we interviewed the archer
for the paralympics who does not have
hands yes and we learned
archer is matt studsman neil yeah we had
we had him on star talk and and that was
quite a show
and he and he was sitting there all
proud and how how he can you know pull
the bow and he's got a family and he
works on his corvette in his garage and
so
so charles that's a beautiful note to
end on thank you for thank you uh
digging into that
bit of
uh social cultural
um
what shall we call that uh
a sense of who we are
and a sense of what society can and
should be
and you heard it here on star talk all
right guys we're going to call it quits
there gary chuck charles always great to
have this this trinity of the three of
you it's a pleasure
working with me on this show this has
been star talk sports edition cosmic
queries grab bag
and i'm neil degrasse tyson uh your
personal astrophysicist
bidding you as always to keep looking up
[Music]